- [Narrator] We brought
together seven drag queens.
- I am a drag queen.
- I'm a drag queen.
- [Narrator] One is a liar.
Who is the odd one out?
- Awesome, what do y'all do?
What do you get into?
Let's start with you.
- Okay what do you mean what I do?
- Like what do you do in drag?
- Oh, I mainly do TikTok
and Instagram stuff.
You guys should follow me, shozydrag.
(laughing)
Yeah, all in my backyard.
- Oh, all in your backyard?
- All in my backyard.
- Where do you live?
- Can't give everyone my location.
(everyone laughing)
- What's your address?
- Well, I thought people
ere getting suspicious of me
just because I don't look like
the typical drag queen, right?
- I guess my (speaks in French)
as the French would say
is, I work with children.
I run an organization called
Drag Queen Story Hour.
We read to kids in libraries, museums.
It's a lot of fun.
I's kind of my shtick.
- I'd say my shtick is I'm a
very much a conceptual queen
so I like to put a lot of
performances based off one idea.
So like this look came to mind
and then I bought a pogo stick,
and then I do a pogo
stick number in heels.
There's an actual pogo stick.
She's back there.
- So my whole gig is I'm more so of a DJ
but I DJ in full drag every single time.
- What's your favorite song to play?
- Right now, Charlie.
Charlie XCX, "Baby."
- Good choice.
- But there's a remix.
I'mma link it to you, it's good.
- I know drag queen DJs,
they usually look a
little bit more haggard
from standing all the time.
Succubus looks really
polished and just a little
too well put together,
and her shoes were obviously just bought.
- Well my thing in drag
is mostly look queen
'cause I can't do the
split to the dips yet,
but I also love to cosplay.
I get my inspiration from
video games and movies.
- I'm from Kansas City by the way.
So I'm actually new to LA
but my first time ever performing in drag
was at Hamburger Mary's Kansas City.
Actually, Widow Von'Du
is actually my drag mom.
So yeah, she's my girl.
She's my... (laughs)
I'm a real drag queen, I swear.
But yeah, you can catch
me on Thursdays at Rocco's
in West Hollywood, I
perform there now, so yeah.
- She said that she performed
at Rocco's every week.
Just with drag in general in LA,
it's harder to break
into West Hollywood drag.
- I mainly do looks.
I'm a makeup artist when I'm not in drag
and then I make everything
myself so I like-
- Stunning.
- Make my outfits, do my wigs.
My makeup is mini, I think though.
- Yeah.
- Let me see that.
- Tell us about your last TikTok.
- My last TikTok?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I was advertising for my show.
I did a TikTok show yesterday.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Had a lot of other drag queens.
It was really fun.
- A lot of other drag queens?
- Yeah.
- What were their names?
- You know, why are you
coming for me right now?
(all laughs)
- She's only got all of us
girls, it's not just you.
- You're asking a lot of questions.
- I know. So maybe-
- I have a lot of questions.
I'm inquisitive.
- I don't know, I don't know.
- You don't know their names?
- No, Iridescence,
there's LA Gaga, Garnet.
- Garnet.
- Garnet, yeah.
- I love her work.
(bell rings)
- She's controlling the conversation
which to me is something that
I thought a mole would do.
- The converse and the
whole backyard story
just wasn't really adding up to me.
- If they're quiet and they're
not sharing anything at all,
they probably don't do drag.
- [Director] It's actually a tie
between Pickle.
- Oh my God. Unbelievable
- And Succubus.
- Oh.
- Gag me a little bit.
- [Director] I'm gonna
actually ask the two of you
to turn around, plug your ears,
and then everyone else,
please come forward
and you have 30 seconds
to come to a consensus.
- She's so overly energetic
and like her personality is a one is A1.
It's to cover up something.
- Who do you think it is?
- Pickle.
- Succubus.
- [Director] Final answer?
All right, everyone turn back.
The person who is
eliminated this round is.
(buzzing)
(clapping)
- Fair enough. Fair enough.
- Your energy is A1.
- Yeah, yeah.
I know, I know.
(laughing)
I know that I probably
seemed like I was like
boopity boop boop boop boop boop,
but it's not my fault
that I'm so charismatic.
- What made you all think
that I was the mole?
- I didn't vote for you.
- I personally did not
vote for you either.
I did not vote for you.
- Oh, I smell a stunt.
- I smell a stunt.
- I can say who I did vote for.
Samantha, I have a question for you.
- Shoot.
- Yeah. You said you perform
at Rocco's every Thursday.
- Starting last month.
- What show is it?
- Show is called "Lady and the Tramp."
And actually there's a
guy that comes up on stage
and I perform with a
guy in the entire time.
We actually make out.
I highly suggest for you to come over
and watch the tramp look me up and down.
- Okay. Yeah. How did you get into Rocco's
'cause Rocco's is really hard
to get into as a new queen.
- Yeah. So actually
I'm really good friends
with Laganja Estranja actually.
We got connected right
when I got out here,
and she performs here all the time
and I was actually really
lucky to be able to get a gig
pretty quick after moving out here so.
- [Bilella] Okay.
- Yeah.
- That was my question.
- That's okay.
No, ask away.
That's what it's for.
Bilella, you need back up sis.
Don't act like you don't
know what's going on Bella...
what's her name again?
Also, you are the youngest queen here.
- Yes
- And also, might I add,
you're a faux queen as well.
Well, how, how would you describe
your drag?
- I would just say drag queen.
- Drag queen. All right.
- I find bio queen, faux
queen terms unnecessary.
I identify as trans.
so in terms like that.
- Beautiful. All right, well
my apologies first of all.
No, you look
absolutely insane.
- Thank you.
- Incredible.
- I like to look more
androgynous out of drag.
As Sugar, I get to be me
still, but extremely feminine
and I love it.
- Also, if I may ask, how
did everyone get their start?
Like what made you wanna do drag?
Well, I started in TikTok.
I just put on a wig and
then I did a little dance
and then it kind of just,
we build over time and now I'm here
and it's fun.
Very much just vibes.
For me, drag is reclaiming
a lot of what I lost in my childhood
due to sexual oppression,
due to internalized homophobia
or just external homophobia
And so drag for me is
reclaiming that life that I lost
and getting to celebrate it
now and being really authentic.
And it's very good for me.
- Yeah. Much better answer than mine.
- Oh no. I'm like
how do I follow that.
- Different journeys, different
journeys. That's okay.
I thought that maybe
the reason why she said
backyard is because she
doesn't technically perform
on stage for audiences.
So I don't know.
I have my eye on you, Shozy.
- So I started doing club in
drag and then I was just like
oh, let's venture,
'cause I consider myself a drag artist.
I don't necessarily say drag queen
'cause it's a box.
And even though we're in a box, but...
(all laugh)
- Well when I came out,
my friend introduced me to "Drag Race"
and it was more like watching that,
and then I was like, oh this is cute.
I'm like let me see if I can do it.
- I started drag because I
fell in love with makeup first.
I had really bad acne
throughout school and stuff
so I kind of got into
makeup because of that.
- Makeup is the same for me.
My mom always had the biggest
makeup collection ever
growing up and so I'd see
it and she'd give me stuff,
and I started doing drag
makeup in my bedroom
at like one in the morning.
I was like I don't want my family to know.
And then my family's super accepting
so they were just like do it,
and they take me everywhere.
They take me to pride,
they do all the things.
- Oh, I love that.
We love a good story.
(bell rings)
- She was dropping a
lot of real girl names.
Widow Von'Du is your drag mom?
I didn't necessarily believe.
- She was just kind of vomiting
anything that she could
to save herself.
- I still voted for Succubus
because I thought everyone else
was gonna vote for Succubus.
(beeping)
(groans)
- I told you I was a
real drag queen y'all.
(laughing)
It's your fault, not mine.
I am a little upset because obviously
this is what I do full time.
Look at me, I literally
have plastic (beep) on.
- [Director] If you think
the mole is still in the box
and you'd like to continue
playing, please raise your hand.
- Okay. So this is the pogo stick.
This is the number.
(cheers)
- Oh my God.
- And that's that.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- You better.
You better.
- Come on drag.
- Better hold that (indistinct).
(cheering)
- Oh, come on.
Come on, bitches.
Come on, yes!
Okay, queen.
- Yes.
Yes.
Yes, please.
- Serve it.
Come on, serving face.
I know that's right.
- Okay. Give me a beat, give me beat.
Let's go, let's go.
- Come on, face.
- Okay.
(cheering)
- My goodness.
- Period.
- Come on backyard queen.
She stretched.
- I did stretch. You saw me out there.
(bell ringing)
- Sneakers for like a drag queen?
Odd one out.
I was just like
it's a little suspicious.
- I just went with Succubus again
just 'cause like I don't
think there's anyone else.
(beeping)
- Wow. I thought we had a sisterhood.
(laughing)
Honestly, I'm pissed
but hey, I mean, vote out
your best competition.
- And then there were four.
- Oh top four.
- [Director] If you think
the mole is still in the box
and you wish to continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
We need a majority vote.
- Who did you think was the mole then?
I'm just curious.
- I thought the mole was Samantha.
- Samantha.
- Yeah.
- I thought it was
Succubus but I don't know,
I like having more money.
I like the idea of more money.
- I don't wanna accuse
you of being the mole.
You just have been so quiet
but I don't,
I haven't heard much from you.
- I mean being the youngest,
I mean, I'm not used to talking
to drag queens in a sense.
I don't go out.
I go to school and that's about it.
- Did you say you don't identify
as a drag artist or a drag
artist but a drag queen?
Like which one would you-
- I identify as a drag queen.
- Drag queen. Okay.
- I use it
because it expresses my femininity
as a non-binary person
instead of out of drag.
- Yeah. I'm fine splitting
it as four people.
- I'm okay with that.
Guess I just looked greedy, okay.
(laughing)
- A little.
- [Director] Okay. If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
If the lights turn green
that means the mole is out and you win.
Ready?
(suspenseful music)
(cheering)
- Money!
Money!
- I'm so sorry.
- No, I get it.
- We did it.
We're winners, baby.
- I know.
- Top four.
- [Director] So on the count of three
will the mole please reveal themselves.
One...
- Two, three.
(clapping)
- I shouldn't have said I was at Rocco's.
I was like I need to
think of a bar right now.
I need to think of a bar
and I need to think of a show.
I'm like (groans).
- You said at Rocco's and I said,
uh-uh, not in West Hollywood.
- Right.
- So I am actually a full-time
influencer and makeup artist.
So I thankfully do have a
lot of drag queen friends.
Laganja is actually a really close
friend of mine.
- Not anymore.
- No, no.
This is actually is Gia Gunn's outfit.
- Oh.
- This is Gia's.
- The beauty.
- The glamor.
- [Director] What are you
leaving here today with?
- Well, not cash
but I am leaving here with
a thought that holy crap,
I really can do anything, honestly.
- I like to say the only
requirement to do drag
is a desire to be fabulous.
- Drag also for me has taught me so much
about my gender and when
Sugar shared different parts
about their identity, I
just could see how drag
was helping transform them.
And I did feel a connection
and just saw the authenticity.
- And I hope other people can see
that there are more than one kind of drag,
more than one type of person can do drag.
- Yes!
(upbeat music)
(cheers)
- We did it!